bom dia
eu sou viviane menina sua mãe da luana
da tainá da naomi e também eu sou
professora pesquisadora e artista visual
e comunicólogos e hoje eu vou falar aqui
pra vocês sobre sonhos eu escolhi esse
tema porque entre os meus alunos muitos
jovens não acreditam nos seus sonhos
então vou contar a minha experiência de
mídia cidadã e vou falar um pouco dessa
experiência em são paulo no pará e vou
falar como eu acreditei no sonho de ser
um artista viajante em 2003 é importante
algumas telas
eu era uma criança gorda muito gordo
obesa e as pessoas odeiam os corpos
então eu cresci sofrendo discriminação
sofrendo bullying e isso fez com que eu
ficasse sensível e prestasse mais
atenção das pessoas excluídas
eu era a classe média alta mas eu não me
identificava com aquele grupo ao qual
pertencia e sendo perseguido e fui
criando mecanismos é mecanismo de
resistência então eu desenhava e pintava
escrevia e de certa forma levava uma
vida bem visível e aí
eu acreditava por muito tempo que sonhar
era melhor que viver mas o que eu não
tinha entendido até então que a pena
sonhar era fugir da realidade não dá pra
fugir da realidade
apesar de ficar invisível as coisas
continuarão acontecendo comigo mas eu
tinha uma rotina que era a casa escola e
aos finais de semana a praia ea praia
galera é um espaço democrático e
subversivo e nesse espaço foi que
encontrei a galera os hips os vendedores
de canga pessoas que viviam na borda da
sociedade e que como eu também eram
invisíveis é isso mudou muito na década
de 90 quando emagreci emagreci
eu comecei a fazer faculdade e eu virei
surfista oferece o fita de ondas grandes
e o que mais me atrai em ser surfista
era o poder do mar os momentos de
solidão os desafios onde você só depende
de você
por outro lado também tinha faculdade
uma coisa nova na minha vida que apesar
de amar cada vez mais a comunicação eu
não me identificava com certos processos
do ensino da publicidade em do meio a
esses conflitos sociais que eu vivia eu
resolvi viajar e descobrir o brasil e aí
eu fui conhecer as praias com ondas
eu participei de muitos campeonatos eu
tomei muitos caldos eu quase morri
afogada nas pedras eu sou feio com
golfinhos e mais importante da minha
experiência como surfista foi que eu eu
tive eu tirei daí os princípios que
regem a minha vida até hoje
eu eu aprendi surfando que quando você
vai surfar você tem que escolher esperar
uma onda chegará esperar a onda certa
quando você escolhe a onda
você tem que remar valendo e aí você tem
que projetar o que você vai fazer
naquela onda e você tem que se jogar
você tem que se jogar valendo ou você
acaba tomando um caldo e isso eu trouxe
para minha vida e isso eu comecei a
fazer principalmente é mudando as minhas
práticas eu comecei a viajar
eu fui para as montanhas de minas para
as praias de floripa eu fui pra porto
alegre
e aí eu abolir a palavra talvez do meu
vocabulário e às vezes eu me dava bem às
vezes me dava mal mas o importante é que
eu comecei a acreditar em mim eu perdi o
medo de arriscar
eu perdi o medo de encarar os meus
sonhos e isso fez com que eu começasse a
modificar e outra outro outro fator
importante que começou a mudar minha
vida foi a filosofia banal das músicas a
filosofia dos livros simples mas que
fazem que fazem a diferença que faz a
abrir os caminhos as portas da percepção
para você então me lembro de dom ranjith
carlos castanheira e o sentido da lenda
pessoal
o coiote o anarquismo de casta de
roberto freire o teatro do oprimido
todas essas experiências me ascenderam a
possibilidade de viver o top camente
professores debate militância anarquia
dos corredores
me fizeram acreditar que eu podia sim
fazer uma faculdade diferente levando
pra minha vida a experiência de
comunicação que eu queria viver
e aí eu percebi que viver é muito melhor
que sonhar eu comecei a juntar grupos de
pessoas que acreditavam nessa
experiência libertária e de mídia cidadã
e juntamos essa utopia de ser possível
criar uma comunicação social e começamos
a nos organizar e começamos a planejar
intervenções na década de 80 e 90 9
internet havia apenas meios de
comunicação de massa e limpo ele
possível a gente pensar e intervir na
notícia do dia seguinte esse era nosso
desafio é ser a nossa experiência era o
momento propício no final da ditadura
fervilhavam grupos sociais experiências
de cidadania e aí a gente criou a
fábrica de sonhos a fábrica de som era
um grupo performático pró cidadania e
direitos humanos que usava assessoria de
imprensa para denunciar a violência e
extermínio c e age ea corrupção ea gente
criava notícia do dia seguinte a gente
denunciava a a venda da carne de
chernobyl e conseguimo proíbe a venda da
carne de chernobyl em são paulo e em
porto alegre
isso foi amplamente noticiado pelos
meios de comunicação de massa na nós
denunciamos é a poluição das praias e
conseguimos implementar que fosse
obrigado se sabe finalizar a
balneabilidade da praia antes não era
permitido por uma placa dizendo pra
imprópria para banho
nós jogamos quilos de peixe no mármore
branco da rampa da assembléia
legislativa e fizeram esgoto naquela
rampa
e nós fomos criando performances que em
92 e 93 é apareciam constantemente nos
grandes veículos de comunicação folha de
são paulo jornal da tarde estado de são
paulo globo é foram 75 publicações sendo
que dessas 75 foram 14 capas matérias de
uma página e meia página ea gente se
juntava a festa cidadã fazendo
jornalismo é alternativo ea gente criava
suas notícias do dia seguinte
inspirados e na não violência ativa de
gandhi inspirados nas ações contra a
globalização do greenpeace se é no
teatro do absurdo do grupo ornitorrinco
de são paulo nos happiness e nas
performances e dessa forma a fábrica de
sonho ela criou um grupo de amigos é que
praticamente fazendo performances
semanais se reuniam pautavam se pelo que
estava sendo publicado nos meios de
comunicação e dava resposta e eram
notícia no dia seguinte é com as suas
performances
ilustrando as lutas e direitos humanos e
a gente se juntou eram jornalistas
pensando a comunicação era publicitárias
pensando ativismo e um arquitetos
pensando a cenografia eram crianças de
rua sem tetos trazendo as suas verdades
e chamando a gente boa pra rua mataram 1
111 no carandiru e a gente ia encenas
encenamos cenas de canibalismo no eco na
eco 92
denunciamos os 111 mortos na chacina do
carandiru
e como é que a gente conseguiu fazer
tudo isso
muitas pessoas querem saber o que você
vai ser quando crescer
é importante a gente deixar claro que
não há escolha definitiva se eu tivesse
escolhido uma coisa teria sido apenas
publicitarem mas não você pode mudar o
rumo
você pode conectar conhecimentos
experiências e interagir
a ti pode ter várias profissões nada
impede a gente pode inclusive inventar
professores que ainda não existem porque
na verdade as soluções do presente não
conta mais do futuro elas vão ter que
ser inventadas por alguém ea gente é
quem inventou o futuro
diante dessa dessa atitude libertária
depois de sete anos a fábrica de sonhos
famosérrima eu decidi que não era mais
aquilo que eu queria eu não estava mais
feliz e fui fazer terapia foi fazer só
uma terapia do roberto freire e uma das
coisas que a sua terapia fala que foi um
outro princípio da minha vida é que sem
tesão não há solução e eu resolvi
assumir aquilo que era lá no começo da
minha vida que era artista visual e eu
comecei a trabalhar é buscar um outro
sentido para a arte que já não me
deixava mais feliz porque eu era um
artista visual que trabalhava para a
moda eu pintava cangas eu pintava
seguindo os padrões das coleções e não
estava mais satisfeita com isso e aí
apareceu uma exposição em são paulo que
foi sensacional eram os artistas
viajantes e eu falei 'não que moda que
nada adoro moda gente nada contra mas eu
quero ser um artista viajante
nada é mais sensacional que redescobrir
o brasil é descobrir a amazônia
sobre o pará e aí eu falei mas será que
é possível em 2000 fui é possível
eu já era artista visual eu se estava
querendo romper com aquela com aquela
que aquela prisão da moda eu resolvi
então vir e descobrir o pará ea minha
história de trágica das performances e
denúncia de extermínio começa a ser uma
fábula colorida porque eu descubro que
havia 11 um projeto e final pap é que
estava mapeando os maquinários pelos
rios da amazônia e eu bato na porta da
professora socorro simões da fpf falou a
professora tem um artista viajante
acompanhando a sua expedição
não minha filha não tem pois professora
eu quero ser esse artista e eu comecei a
acompanhar as expedições pelos rios da
amazônia é e foi desenhando essa
amazônia descobrindo essa amazônia com
as crianças no estreito de breves
descobrindo vários personagens que
moravam longo dos rios e fazendo
aquarela sobre seda descobrindo as
culturas as festas do de cametá às os
cordões de mascarados e descobrindo os
rios descobrir no rio a tocou eu fui pra
programa xingu e vi aquela barragem do
rio xingu sendo projetada
eu fui pra cametá e vi o rio tocantins
impedido e não as pessoas não podiam
entrar no tocantins por causa do
assoreamento do rio por causa da
hidrelétrica de tucuruí e eu fui pra
etapa jorge descobrir me apaixonei por
alter do chão e de repente ouvi que
alter do chão
ameaçado por causa da construção das
hidrelétricas
e fui pro rio trombetas e descobri que
naquela no oeste paraense
o pôr do sol mais bonito do planeta é
vermelho laranja e acontece em oriximiná
e viu círio fluvial de oriximiná e vi
encontrei as crianças que pegam canoa e
pegam carona nos barcos vendendo seus
produtos e assim eu fiquei encantada com
a possibilidade de ter dois verões por
ano 11 em são paulo em janeiro e outra
em julho no pará e desenhei pintem seda
mapeei o pará viajando pelos rios
encontrei os brincantes encontrei os
indígenas e fiz esse relato em várias
vários suportes é publiquei em revistas
fc uma dissertação de mestrado em they e
virei um ativista da cultura popular
mas depois de um tempo eu entrei na
faculdade tinha feito mestrado e comecei
a dar aula e era minha chance de eu
criar um modelo de comunicação que eu
acreditava e aí eu transformei a
faculdade estácio em uma grande fábrica
de sonhos eu me apropriei de todos os
espaços ea marquise em todos os espaços
e assim que eu dou aula e é assim que eu
faço a extensão
a gente cria a gente assumir projetos a
gente vibra e agente reformulou os
espaços e eu estava tão feliz com isso
que eu parei de viajar mas mantendo a
disciplina cultura brasileira descobriu
que as pessoas tinham preconceito de 100
indígenas que as pessoas não entendiam
que ela vive na amazônia aí eu falei ah
não quero mais isso vou mudar de novo e
aí
eu comecei a levar para dentro da
faculdade os indígenas levar para dentro
da faculdade
os ribeirinhos e aí eu resolvi levar os
alunos também para a amazônia
todos esses pontos santarém oriximiná
monte alegre cametá melgaço curralinho
eu e os meus alunos estivermos e
produzimos é cartografias fomos pra
festivais e e assim fazendo parceria com
vários grupos nós viajamos para o
carimbó da área do salgado com a ufpa
fizemos parceria institucional com a
polícia pra é fazer uma cartografia do
marajó
os indígenas nas festas nos parkatêjê é
com os professores é pra fazer o
mapeamento das pinturas rupestres de
monte alegre é e também fizemos o
primeiro tcc na aldeia é viajamos é com
a galera do cesupa fomos pra propor
marajó e implementar tecnologias sociais
gente é só convidar que a gente topa
mesmo né a gente vai aprendendo como uma
pará dormir rede é vai comprar
aprendendo a fazer pintura corporal e
vai aprendendo a fazer fotografia e vai
aprendendo a fazer jornalismo e vai
aprendendo a fazer comunicação
comunitária vai enxergando as mazelas da
amazônia por onde passo as nossas
riquezas
assim os conflitos das regiões em torno
de belém nós estamos no combo pensando
combo e nós também saímos do pará porque
a gente tem que se conectar com o brasil
e com o mundo ea gente foi para o rio
+20 entender como é que rolava os
processos de redes e conexões em redes
pra levar nossa mensagem amazônica fomos
o xingu mais 23 também pra cá na luta
junto com as comunidades que estão as
bordas submersas nessa amazônia que não
é enxergado é explorada é contaminada ea
gente está nas lutas
a gente está na história a gente tá
lutando contra o golpe ea gente está
envolvendo os alunos e os alunos
sonhadores produzem peças interessantes
pra isso
eles produzem até hq s como carbono e de
quem o grupo atuba são aqueles que falam
de problemas de comunicação que falam de
problemas de preservação que falam do
brega sampleados uma websérie que fala
do breve trailer wu parar pra outras
dimensões conectando os bregas
tradicionais juventude universitária
pelas causas indígenas uma fanpage
conector indígenas e não indígenas e dar
uma voz para as causas os mestres
tradicionais os mestres exóticos no
nosso pará os mestres poetas populares a
gente faz show produz e b
enfim a gente busca inovar na linguagem
criar uma linguagem lúdica uma linguagem
política uma linguagem que mobiliza
através da imagem ea gente vai inovador
ditamos graças aos nossos alunos somos
também jornalistas livres ao novo
projeto de extensão da estácio e era
isso que tinha pra falar pra vocês mas
todos esses sonhos galera
todos esses momentos eu tenho que falar
que só aconteceu por causa de uma
parceria imensa e um segredo que eu
nunca revelei é que nenhum desses
projetos
eu tinha certeza que ia dar certo
eu olhei eu enxerguei eu acreditei eu
remei criei minha estratégia e me joguei
me joguei com tudo no meu sonho e era
isso que eu tinha pra falar pra vocês eu
queria agradecer a paciência
obrigada